on va en parler jean-marie t'as pas une
petite blague là pour démarrer comme ça
si c'est une jeune femme qui fait ses
causes justes
[Rires]
michaud femme égale jeune femme l'ex
foncia texte
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
jean-marie dj pascal lui damer le thin
jeune femme qui fait ses courses elle
achète une bonne âme c'est un poireau
rien de rigueur là dedans un kiwi une
petite pizzetti n'a cuisiner pour une
personne elle arrive à la caisse le
caissier il lui sourit pas ses articles
ce truc puis la regarde que c'est dit
vous êtes seul un a dit oui c'est vrai
je suis seul mais comment vous avez
deviné on va a dit ça c'est facile vous
est moche
[Applaudissements]
mais un coup de stars pilote il faut
boire un petit peu de guronsan comme ça
j'ai même fait un beat by le vrai drame
c'est que jean-michel mardi si elle est
bonne mais qui dit à sa femme je te fais
bien l'amour ce soir attendez laissez
médical regard je ferais bien le mot
social dit ben non shea ça tombe mal
puisque ce moment j'ai des pertes
blanches c'est grâce à mme sahab
marie dit c'est pas grave moi j'ai du
diabète on va faire des meringues
[Applaudissements]
merci
[Musique]
là dedans non j'ai pas fait rire la
france soit dans 20 mai si c'est la
selmer
il a de quoi faire et la france pendant
deux secondes alors que nous a fait don
d'une petite dernière est d'aller eux
mais qu'il est dans un compartiment se
retrouve seul en face d'une dame très
élégante très joli cas une jupe un petit
peu courte
à nous quatre un débat par tu vas voir
c'est une fille qui a de la classe et
les décomplexer complètement est la
preuve
elle croise un décroise ses jambes
plusieurs fois maman le mec peut pas et
peut pas ne pas voir qu'elle n'a pas de
culotte toi il est un peu étonné un
moment la jeune femme a lui dit est
belle hein elle vous plaît alors il est
tétanisé absolument me fâche un petit
peu ému il ya j'avais je vous êtes un
gentleman
regardez ce que je vais vous faire les
cartes les jambes l'hôte il a les yeux
rivés sur la seiche ou binette et dire
regardez bien elle va vous faire un clin
d'oeil
et là il voit la choupinette de dames
qui store qui potash a fait un clin
d'oeil wa10 est incroyable et sfr de
trucs unis oui regardez par exemple
regardez bien maintenant elle va vous
faire un bisou france et voit les
shopping ou presque avec le bruit tu
sais que vous êtes gentils venez vous
asseoir à côté de moi plus près et
risquent pas prier ce même tout près les
îles acquis duré 20 minutes
au finish et mais si vous me lâche y est
ici bien ça venait d'y aller que vous
êtes gentil si vous voulez vous pouvez
me mettre deux doigts et elle veut dire
non ne me dit pas quels ces sifflets
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
familiale lé pa li nian mairie je n'y
croyais pas mais l'effet médias